I gotta say happy belated thank you you
and Catherine both thank you yes and
almost 20 years of marriage 20 years of
marriage we have the same birthday it
sounded very romantic when we first got
together now Catherine hates she wants
to get a room day I don't blame her you
know what's the wrong birthday what I
have to share with you guys both deserve
your own that's true yeah what is the
secret now that it's been nearly 20
years
is there one I feel like you know one
thing I do find is sometimes you make
more of an effort with strangers that we
do the people closest to us we try to
show how nice fear of strangers and can
take the person closest to us for
granted or maybe as I've learned over
the years just to monitor and to cherish
and part of us getting older too because
you have a finite amount of time left
you know and might as well make it as
best as I can so I try to be as
considerate as I can Michael Douglas
talking all about his famous family with
et he's gearing up for the Kaminski
method season 2 and this time his
daughter on the show finds love with a
much older man played by Paul Reiser her
boyfriend turns out to be someone close
to my age almost as old as her father
Paul Reiser
who's a brilliant comedian and wonderful
actor this is Christ Mindy your daughter
in real life 16 how do you handle her
dating she's still pretty pure about
about all this she's looking for a
boyfriend but she's in this in this new
vernacular everybody's a friend and
we're friends okay what do you mean your
friends I mean I understand your no
we're friends and this is what happens
by meiosis is like 19 and they start
like can I invite someone so for a
sleepover a bunch of us yeah it's like
six or seven and they fight girls over
there what's going on no no dad their
friends come on we're friends and it's
beautiful to watch actually I mean I
mean me with my you know paranoid images
and then see these you know kids get
along so III haven't had to deal with it
you know directly right on in terms of
she's not fest up yet to having
boyfriend she's on the look she's
looking around what is she looking for
that's a good question looking for love
looking for love I don't know she's I
think I know the Cable Guy said she
likes said she likes her kind of the
dark Latin Wow okay Alejandro's one she
likes yeah we told you he's spilling a
lot you're protective dad I'm sure I
will be yeah I I'm I'm sure I give a lot
of unsolicited advice which is not a
great idea but I can't help I think it's
a good idea like what what advice
well you just been dating you really
just you know you gotta decide at an
early age if you're more concerned about
the looks versus who's got a good heart
he's got a good sense of humor who's got
a good partner so I think but I don't
worry too much about her she's using
cream cheese that's the advice he gives
his kids but his own dad Kirk has shared
wisdom with Michael over the years -
what's the best parenting advice that
your father ever gave you I don't know
but as a parent it might be just in
actions at whatever you do whatever you
do in life just do it to the utmost
ability do it as with full commitment
and then screw it doesn't work out move
on but you know and you're left with the
idea that there's nothing more you could
have done we were also wondering when
we'd see him share the screen again with
wife Catherine zeta-jones we'd love to
see Catherine guest star okay it's an
idea all right
talk to her talk to her I I have a weave
we'd love to do things together we did
one picture traffic years ago allow me
to have much to do together and I guess
we haven't because we always like to
have earlier on when when one of us was
home you know for the kids thank you one
person was home but now now there were
pretty much empty nesters who might
consider that but this season of the
show has a
lots of guest stars including Jane
Seymour who they aged up a bit she told
me that you didn't recognize her I do
not recognize I've known her for 40
years and she walked in and I introduced
myself and [ __ ] Michael yeah it's Jane
Jane she had a wig on I was aging
herself up a little bit but she looks
pretty damn good
gorgeous gorgeous so that was great and
then I didn't know that chuck was gonna
introduce an ex-wife for me
and so we talked a little bit about who
should be my ex-wife and I said why not
Kathleen Turner and he said yes that's
great yeah so we do a little bit of a
War of the Roses routine together or I'm
looking forward to spending some some
more time with her there's many more to
come
which I'm not allowed to mention this is
the tease and let us tell ya the new
season is a journey I think Chuck Lorre
thought maybe it was time for sandy
Kaminski my character to have to deal
with a few issues I enjoyed it
health issues something you deal with
that at this age
I love the the acting classes he had I
think you saw more of his ability and
his talent of working with students his
love life continues to to be a mess I
think you cherish their their friendship
you understand and I'm really now I've
getting some information and on the
viewing audience kind of really
surprised but the younger audience that
this shows god yes exactly I told you I
loved it yeah I don't know what it is
exactly other than maybe that people see
the foibles of older people rather than
always seeing older people that image of
politicians of having the answers or
authoritarian or this you kind of see
them the way we all really are is we
still don't know what's always what's
right what's what's wrong
life is a rollercoaster in life is a
rollercoaster this bill has been really
a tree